well let's dig into all things season
three and we'll start kind of where the
season starts of you and christine
trying to repair this thing that used to
be a friendship
i just don't know where all of this is
coming from
you know we tried to have a conversation
we tried to talk it through and then i
find out you call me
idiot it just feels like you're so angry
at me it's always been really hard to
talk to you it seems like you get to
a place but it doesn't seem like it's
the place you want to be
right that's accurate we you know take a
couple steps forward
take a couple back so i still i still
have hope
but it's it's just going to take a lot
more to get there i think
how do you feel about where you guys
left it
i feel sad about where we left it's
unfortunate
um i just feel like you know
all odds were working against us and we
were
trying to connect one-on-one but i never
really had a chance to
get time alone with her and sit down
with her and be like hey can i talk to
you can we actually talk alone
so i feel like that was you know the
hardest part and also yesterday i was
i was cleaning my house and god this is
gonna make the tear up
but i saw a photo of us on her birthday
from years ago and um that was the first
birthday that i wasn't at
so was this year so it was really hard
yeah i want to be in a good place with
her i do
it sucks i was gonna say what did you
think when you saw
that birthday party that only some of
you guys were invited to
i was really hurt but obviously i'm not
surprised
after the show i mean it's hard it did
affect our relationships i
you know i'd be lying if i said it it
didn't destroy them
um so i was hurt from your perspective
what
changed in your relationship between
season one we
saw you as kind of former roommates who
were still very close friends
to season two it was almost like you
barely knew each other
well i think that christelle situation
was
just the main point where it all started
i think davina was a catalyst
in all of it stirring up trouble um and
getting this whole thing going
and then since then there's just been a
lot that's happened a lot that's been
said
that that is not conducive to
a friendship and so
uh i i don't really know where to go
with it um i just have been trying to
keep my distance
because because i just don't want that
in my life and it's one thing to
hear she said something about you it's
another thing and this is a unique
experience to reality tv to see what it
was
apparently after you left the brokers
open
christine went into the whole group and
was like mimicking you
she never talks straight so when you
don't talk straight it makes you look
like a [ __ ] idiot
she was like doing her impression of you
like
she just and talks in circles
well my sister was in town and this and
that
do you now regret
the comments you made about her at the
broker's open or
no of course not no no that was
oh it was hilarious and it's true it
just wasn't the time to do it and
um she wasn't ready to have that
conversation so
my intentions remain the same i just was
trying to talk to her
what was your reaction to that moment at
the broker's open
i was shocked i i was i'm
hurt and shocked and
i just didn't i i've seen her go off on
other people
i just never thought it would be towards
me and and
so it's just kind of like this
revelation of
do i know this person do i want this
person in my life
um and i keep trying to take it back and
be like no this is
i i remember the old christine she
wouldn't do this and so
maybe it's just circumstances that that
makes
it feel like we're different people um
i hope that's what it is because it's
it's just a completely different
relationship
and completely different trust um
towards her
like or lack of trust that um that i've
got now
so those circumstances do you mean the
show
yeah i mean i think so the show um
more or less the the interviews i think
sorry about the interviews
um that where nothing ever dies we keep
getting asked questions and questions
and questions and so it just
snowballs rather than anything so i
think yeah i think it's more
um the what comes from the show
rather than this show the show is just
filming our life us talking about it
after makes it
right a bigger situation it's like in tv
land it's like
it's like all i want to do is keep
talking about that's not real you know
that's not
really how we do it sometimes you do
make a little bit of a stink about a
manza being this wedge between you
this like pitbull that protects mary
doesn't give you access to mary do you
still feel that way now
oh my god amanda and i are best friends
no we talk every single day
i'm flattered i wouldn't consider
christine of
my i wouldn't consider her my best
friend
i would consider her a close friend but
let's just say that amanda
amanza and i are on really really great
terms and i love her i
talk to her every day what did you make
of her putting the blame on a man's she
also calls a man
it's just silly yeah it's just silly you
know amanda's obviously she's protective
of me she's mama bear
um and she always has been but amanda's
been my absolute best friend for
20 years so she's been around she comes
across
like really [ __ ] and then like she
backpedals like no guys it's just for
the show i'm really sweet it's like
okay well you didn't tell me that you
thought it was cherry tree
it's been real christine gabriel
annoying i know this is like a charity
event i'm like this is charity
by me like sitting here like i should be
bidding on this oh my god
i had a nail appointment i had to go to
i made it very clear ariana grande's
girls does my nails like
yeah i had a nail appointment sorry
i was grossed out i was like that's
really low that's classless
and a low blow but then she left and i
was like well i i didn't leave the chair
you're the one that left with your head
down i was just
a little bit confused about the whole
thing it's
it's so cringy to me christine you know
she's really sweet
like she really is she gets a bad rap
because she that's how she comes across
on the show but it's kind of like well
you late
make your bed you lay in it you're a
[ __ ] on the show like you can't
say really [ __ ] stuff and then get
upset when the world is like
you're a [ __ ] because you did that you
know like
they don't make you say anything it's
not scripted